bonsoir Monsieur
c'est un univers un peu
obscur là pour certaines personnes qui
nous regardent monsieur la S c'est quoi
l'industrie du e-sport du sport
électronique qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
ça le sport électronique le sport c'est
une nouvelle forme de divertissement le
gaming le jeu vidéo c'est en fait la
plus grosse forme de divertissement du
monde en tant que revenu et au sein du
gaming existe le sport et c'est en fait
les compétitions très souvent de très
haut niveau entre quai organisés à
Toronto à Los Angel à Shanghai qui se
rencontrent des jeux comme League of
Legends et autres pour savoir qui est le
meilleur et faire compétition tout
simplement c'est ça des compétitions
internationales et vous vous avez
atterri dans l'univers des sports
électroniques de quelle manière et
qu'est-ce que vous faites chez United is
born moi j'ai atterri donc j'étais tout
petit c'était pas encore organisé comme
c'est aujourd'hui je jouais à des jeux
et j'ai fait ma carrière dans les médias
je jouais un peu au sport quand j'étais
à l'universitaire et j'ai vu quelques
années que les sports
avaient non seulement bien grandi mais
elle est continuer grandir donc on a
créé une compagnie d'une Nathalie sport
qui était un peu dans la lignée de ce
que je veux avant dans la musique
médiane et qui est devenu une des
meilleures moi je pense que c'est
accompagné dans le média à Los Angel
autour du sport du gaming très bien donc
là vous êtes basé à Los Angeles
l'Amérique du Nord se le dit c'est pas
le plus gros marché nécessairement pour
le sport électronique ça se passe où le
plus gros de vos activités c'est à quel
endroit nous on a une compagnie
américaine donc on fait beaucoup de ce
qu'on fait en Amérique du Nord on a
quelques activités assez haut et à Hong
Kong je pense d'après moi que les
marchés asiatiques du sport sont sur
beaucoup de choses les plus intéressants
on a beaucoup de la culture du sport qui
vient d'Amérique du nord des États-Unis
et du Canada et il y a une très bonne
culture européenne aussi mais on voit
vraiment que ce sont trois marchés bien
séparés dans leur approche par rapport
au sport même si les équipes vont se
faire compétition les autres alors
qu'elles sont dans différents marchés
parfois quelquefois par an ce qu'on a
observé dans les dernières années avec
la pandémie entre autres c'est que ça a
été extrêmement bénéfique pour le
secteur ça a tirait encore plus de
joueurs plus d'intérêt pour les
compétitions sportives si on veut de
jeux vidéo et même la jeune génération
connaît parfois plus les vedettes du
e-sport que les vedettes de la Ligue
nationale de hockey par exemple est-ce
que ce sont eux qui génèrent vos revenus
se sont eux le plus grand taux d'hitoire
si on veut ça c'est sûr que la
génération Z les gens qui ont en dessous
de 25 ans c'est les gens qui sont en
général les plus intéressés au sport et
au gaming certaines statistiques vont
dire que jusqu'à 95% de cette génération
Z participe au gaming on voit qu'une
petite différence dans les sports
algaming l'un par rapport à l'autre l'un
est contenu dans l'autre mais pour nous
c'est évidemment cette génération là
avec qui on parle plus tous les jours à
la fois avec nos médias et nos
commanditaires nos partenaires etc
est-ce que c'est une industrie en
croissance on a vu ce baume de
popularité si vous voulez avec la
pandémie là on est dans un contexte
économique un peu particulier où on
parle le ralentissement de l'économie de
possibilité de récession et on a des
annonceurs entre autres qui sont plus
frileux qui injecte moins d'argent et ça
fonctionne par publicité le modèle
d'affaires du sport est-ce que est-ce
que ça peut toucher l'industrie est-ce
que ça peut la faire ralentir on a vu
qu'il y a un peu de on veut dire un
ralentissement au sein de la croissance
l'audimat continue de grandir on voit
tous les jours de plus en plus de gens
qui regardent qui participent qui
s'impliquent on a eu énormément de
croissance il y a quelques années
évidemment avec un gros boost pendant la
Coz ça continue de grandir ça grandit un
peu moins vite qu'avant certaines
compagnies se font remplacer petit à
petit au sein du sport mais évidemment
j'ai des 10 mA carrières donc je pense
que ça va continuer grandir absolument
et là c'est particulier parce que
enfin un rapprochement entre les sports
électroniques et le Mouvement olympique
c'était la première semaine olympique
des eSports qui viennent se tenir à
Singapour les prochains Jeux d'Asie en
septembre vont remettre de vrais
médailles d'ailleurs au gagnant des
épreuves de sport électronique est-ce
que vous voyez ça d'un bonheur je vois
ça donner mitigé je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose pour le sport en soi il
y a deux opinions au sein du sport il y
a des gens qui pensent que ça doit
s'inspirer complètement du modèle
sportif et d'autres qui pensent un peu
comme moi que ça peut on peut continuer
de créer vraiment notre propre univers
donc je pense que ça peut pas être une
mauvaise chose mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on approche progressivement et c'est
un très grand débat dans notre industrie
clairement on va terminer sur cette
question peut-être plus délicate
monsieur Lahaye on a l'impression qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de femmes dans ces
milieux très pointus est-ce que c'est le
cas dans les eSports il y a une très
grande différence sur ce point là
générationnel la génération Z encore un
sont un beaucoup plus de représentations
des femmes dans l'espoir je pense ou le
gaming en tout cas certaines
statistiques vont dire que c'est 45 55
48 52 donc ça a un vrai changement
culturel on voit beaucoup de femmes qui
sont appliquées dans le gaming et donc
le sport très bien c'est effectivement
un revirement de situation puisque dans
les dernières années c'était plutôt le
contraire en domination masculine plutôt
dans ces dans ce cette industrie je vous
remercie beaucoup d'être passé sur ce
plateau ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]